Sakshi something wrong bad I love you
too
really nice have any more kids started
you wanted a big family he or she's
really cute
I'm Angela Morgan Katie well whose love
that's Katie my playdate
here it is with me run let's all raise a
glass I just feel like I'm part of the
family now
my mom said kid is it a Lily's your
mother doesn't like anyone want you to
move your guest house you can also be a
part-time nanny Angela and Bryan are
going to try for another kids they're
going to use a surrogate it's a good
mystery mommy resuming their my baby we
won't have the family that we wanted uh
no not at all - if you don't know any of
this - what in cadiz not with it she's
very beautiful isn't she
[Music]
it is last thing when I heard a
questioning or one of them holding our
girl they looked just like you
yeah I get that all the time she's not
your daughter this is your job yes we
have your case and kerri-anne you're
hiding something
and I'm going to find out what it is I
think she may be mentally unwell
possibly they know we don't know
anything about this will impure drug
addict I rather died as a child is
endangered the baby katie has grounds
for keeping him now fine a contagious
aesthetic you're sure served murder
you stay away from me
you're gonna kill me
[Music]
you